the u.s motorist is already feeling the
pain
the price of gas is now at its highest
level since the economic crash in 2008
and this could rise even further should
the u.s decide to impose sanctions on
russian oil
well no decision has been made at this
point uh by the president about uh an uh
a ban an import a ban on importing oil
from russia
and those discussions are ongoing
internally and also with our
counterparts uh and partners in europe
and around the world i would note that
what the president is most focused on is
ensuring we are continuing to take steps
uh to deliver punishing economic
consequences on putin while taking all
action necessary to limit the impact to
prices at the gas pump
the us is the world's largest oil
producer but is also the largest
consumer and remains dependent on
imported foreign oil
eight percent of oil imported into the
us comes from russia and the bidet
administration is seeking ways to make
up the shortfall should it impose
sanctions
the white house confirmed a high-level
team visited venezuela this weekend to
discuss among other issues energy
matters
there's also been speculation about
importing oil from iran
and while this broad bipartisan support
for oil sanctions against russia in
congress there's fury among republicans
about any suggestion that countries like
venezuela or iran could make up the
shortfall
we should be drilling for oil and gas
that we own to replace what we buy from
putin and the idea of getting gas from
iran to make up for the loss we receive
from russia is insane
you'd be taking
gas revenue away from a dictator a war
criminal
and increasing revenue for a religious
nazi the ayatollah of iran that is the
dumbest idea i've ever heard
we are producing over a million dollars
less a day than we were just a couple
years ago we have the capability to do
it i think that's a much better strategy
than begging saudi arabia to produce
more or cutting a deal with a narco
terrorist and maduro in venezuela which
wouldn't even lead to enough oil anyways
or some
you know crazy iran deal that almost
guarantees there'll be a nuclear weapons
power
underlying the biden administration's
deliberations about oil sanctions
against russia are domestic political
concerns
prices at the pump are an electric rail
in u.s politics and looming ahead later
this year are midterm elections in which
high gas prices could have severe
consequences for the administration in
charge regardless of the reason
mike hanna al jazeera washington